Trump is the lion and they called you
know the Maga party the Maga symbol is
the lion what's Ron and what's Vivek
Ron's the Rhino
the fake the snake Rama
oh that's mean no those are both it's a
dangerously powerful creature of the
snake the Rhino and the fake the snake
yeah geez Trump supporter Maga 2024 Ian
over here no well I think I've called
for Vic I said that I like to snake
probably like three months ago because
what I see in him is that he's not
playing his hand you don't know what
he's got and he's a not a billionaire
have a brilliant strategist the guy is a
is a hunt was hundreds of millions of
dollars wow Donald Trump is going to
come out in the primaries and be like
rhino run and Vivek the snake
Donald Trump it's Donald Trump all the
way that's if you they want to hit
Donald it's Donald Trump if could you
imagine if Trump starts using Ian's
the snake Robert you know Jake the Snake
Roberts